MEL YOUNG >> Hi-um. Hi, YouTube. I'm Mel Young.
Um-I'm here at-ah-the world economic forum
at Davos. I'm President of the homeless World
Cup. I'm often asked here whether I'm pessimistic
or optimistic. And I'm optimistic-ah-because
I think although the world has-ah-problems
economically, there's lots of ways out of
this. And what we need to do is change the
mood and the mood is about compromise.
The area I work in, in particular, is sport
and-um-I think there's a huge opportunity
for the values of sport-ah-which are about
teamwork, togetherness, a willingness to achieve-ah-victory
and adversity. Linked with our understanding
of sport is a sizable chunk of-of the industry
in-in the world. I think it's 2% of the GDP-ah-globally.
So I think sport, if you start to look at
it not only in terms of its value in industry,
but in terms of the values that it has and
apply these across all sections, then you
start to have some answers.
So I'm optimistic about the future.